in 2000 harper's magazine sent writer
James McManus to Las Vegas where he
would simultaneously cover the world
series of poker and the Ted Binion
murder trial along the way he earned a
seat at the final table of the 23
million dollar event recently mr.
McManus sat down with chicago tribune
columnist Rick Cogan to discuss his
story and the new book positively fifth
Street it's about 50 minutes I'm Rick
Cogan I work for the Tribune I play some
amateur poker with a bunch of guys I
don't know if Jim will appreciate this
bunch of the same bunch of guys have
been playing with since I was 18 years
old so there is no such thing as
bluffing there is no such thing as card
playing it we all know each other's game
so well this is Jim McManus oh you've
all come to see some of you we were just
standing outside and this guy in the
yellow shirt comes up and says me and my
buddies who play poker really love your
books I have the feeling this is like
there may be some very interesting
things going on at night where guys
and/or guys and women are playing poker
and then the poker game sort of
transforms into a book club which I
think would be fantastic Beck in 1986
the Tribune wrote this there were 86
people to watch in 86 James McManus 34
author still awaiting quote best-selling
list unquote status McManus has
published two books this year Chin Music
a novel and curtains a collection of
short stories he's working now with a
new publisher to have two of his books
out of the blue and Chin Music published
in paperback in 1986 he has another
novel underway that he hopes will
publish be published this year in
addition to writing he teaches
literature and writing at the school of
the Art Institute Chin Music brought in
mixed reviews ranging from enthusiastic
to quote apoplectic on fo
as McManus described it curtains which
has received some accolades mayfair
better as of today is latest book
positively fifth Street for those of you
who have not read it is a fabulous rate
I think of it sort of as almost three
books in one what's it feel like to be
number 15 on the New York Times
bestseller list I think this is kind of
there's an irony in this is there not uh
I feels worse than being 14 which we
were last week we're steadily sinking
but that must mean that it has literary
artistic value because when I was going
up on the list i thought that commercial
viability was real important and now i
think that if it sells fewer copies then
that shows that it's exquisite writing
we're talking outside about the fact
that Jim's books his novels and
collection if you haven't read them and
you've read this this should spur you to
go read those you think I think when
you're sitting down to write a short
story and or a novel you think to
yourself as a writer why this is really
a good idea you don't know if it's going
to sell you can't go into it predicting
if it's going to sell did you know Jim
when the Harper's assignment came and
Liz Lapham said simply to you have fun
and write a good story any clue about
what you'd stumbled on here uh it was a
number of surprises occurred one the
fact that I had wanted to play in this
tournament for 15 or 20 years to the
fact that I was covering the women the
murder trial it seemed like something
that a novelist and that was almost all
my experience was as
as a novelist that the material was
going to be rich and pregnant with a
possibility I didn't anticipate that so
many things would dovetail in at one
point at the end of the week the fact
that the trial at the tournament ended
on Thursday the trial ended on friday
and that I was an integral actor in both
of those dramas sort of added my story
to the mix it was it was all of a very
pleasant surprise a serendipitous kind
of right venture in Las Vegas yeah lewis
lapham had asked me for five thousand
words but by the time I made the final
table in the tournament they were they
wanted yell bet they did longer piece
even Harper's knows what a good story is
when they stumble on one the book begins
uh and this is a very interesting sort
of I'm not sure it's a literary device
but it's a very interesting way of
beginning it yeah I knew this story
about the the whole binion thing and
will tell you for those of you don't
know what the book i'll have Jim kind of
explain it but it starts with a sort of
a fictionalization of an EVA a real
event I'm really curious about why you
started that way it almost seems as if
you said to yourself well now I'm a
fiction writer and this may be a really
good way to get into it and I'll be
exercising muscles that I know right
right that was the first chapter is not
the first thing that I wrote what
happened was the main events of the
story take place in the spring of two
thousand May at Binion's Horseshoe in
downtown Las Vegas and at the Clark
County Courthouse one block away so that
as I'm going back and forth it seemed
like the story began when the murder
took place which was in September of
1998 so that as
various pieces of the murder or at that
point the alleged murder fell into place
people including myself imagined how the
murder had actually gone down since the
since the two people accused of the
crime did not admit to it the one needed
to use their imagination at least a
little bit too to be able to piece
together how it probably happened given
the evidence that was had it been
introduced in court so when did you make
the trust to begin it than to begin the
book that way I mean you obviously had
tons of notes you were you were not only
you were a journalist on this story in
the first place then you became kind of
parts of the book or fascinating history
of Vegas of even paper at one point and
I didn't know this that the Chinese
invented paper and the first uses for it
were were money paper and cards which is
quite something he begins the book and
tell me those of you who have not read
it that you could stop reading a book
after this I pride myself on writing
kind of interesting leads for the paper
this is a good lead as they call it a
nubile blonde squats on her boyfriends
bare chest and he's too stoned to do
much about it who would not read the
next sentence that's one of the
interesting things about this is you
really do grab people and for those of
you who are not going to spoil the whole
story here so much of it is about Jim
himself which is a bold and very risky
thing for a writer to do especially in a
nonfiction book because in a novel it
can be dead about you but you don't have
to admit it's about you do you know what
I mean does that make any sense well the
way I got around that was i divided my
character into good gym in Belgium which
I think with corresponds to reality
pretty much
on a related point i think it's it's
real easy for guys who are poker players
to like this book and so far that has
been its main audience but in all
sincerity I really feel that it's it's a
love story between my wife jennifer and
I she's she's here today she doesn't go
come to all the book events but she's
here today Ted Binion Ted Binion's first
wife left him and he was in Las Vegas
and he went to cheetahs topless club and
met sandy Murphy and invited her to move
into his house and my first wife left me
in 1988 and I met Jennifer and
thatthat's it's practically the only
reason that I'm here today and he is
where he is in the ground in Las Vegas I
mean that that's I think that's the
theme the story of the book there's a
lot of poker in it there's a lot about
Las Vegas but really it's about getting
lucky or unlucky in love and I think
that the ways that that plays out in the
poker world and the sexual world and in
the just about every dimension of life
is is really what it's about so I
there's a chapter in the book called
chicks with Dex which is the slang word
for women poker players but for other
reasons I hope that the chicks will pick
the book up to well chick should pick it
up if they have husbands around our age
because it is also very much about and
of getting older Jim rights in the book
my competitive impulses used to be
satisfied playing baseball golf hockey
this could be me hockey tennis and
basketball by rooting for the Bears
Bulls Blackhawks Yankees White Sox and
whoever was playing the cub I'll see the
Yankees today yeah you must be angry
about that game yesterday then he writes
a few paragraphs later so the main thing
i love about poker is that it's gotten
me back in the action and i doubt it's a
coincidence that the rhythms
baseball my best support 30 or 40 years
ago readily transferred to the poker
table I dare say that everybody who
plays poker with any regularity and jim
has a game you know off law office near
greektown was that a weekly game you
played I was a weekly game it was held
in the offices of Ian elphaba how do you
say your last name Ian it's just Ian
elfin bomb yeah that's right you keep
those gray you should write your last
names even be known that's right that's
right he doesn't know what I'm talking
about anyway that game I don't know
anything a game what game yeah that game
is an ongoing game and there's a couple
other ones it the Chicago's a great town
for home games it's four tournaments and
high stakes poker is the worst city
Illinois is the worst state in the
country most of the rest of the country
has become enlightened as to the very
real differences between gambling in a
poker game where there's skill and a lot
less recklessness involved than in
traditional casino games like craps
blackjack roulette and so on and then
the rest of the country poker is not
resented by the people who run the
casinos and you can go in especially in
places like California in Las Vegas that
poker players are treated much better
than they are treated around here the
changing face of Poker how many people
in this audience play poker with any
regularity that is something that's
pretty small yeah this is a more fan
base here this is a new fan base you've
discovered one of the things anybody how
many people here have been to Las Vegas
well slot players are in one of the
things that that Jim another thing that
he touches on in the book is the
changing face of Poker even in Las Vegas
it is now I'd hazard to say sort of the
most proletariat game there are people
not of every age but certainly both
sexes every conceivable ethnic group
every conceivable political opinion or
education level
is that the result Jim of of Technology
do you think because and tell them how
you practiced to get out there because i
think that addresses it to for 200 years
poker was dominated by men particularly
men who could do well in illegal or
quasi legal situations you needed to be
tough you needed to be a comfortable
plane in in a game where the police
would be coming after you the local goon
squad might be coming after you and that
definitely limited the number of people
and the the kinds of people who could
enter the game in the mid-1980s
California the California Legislature
decided that they would legalize poker
keep the other casino games illegal and
that one of the results of that is that
women regular folks people who didn't
carry sawed-off shotguns or switch
blades around with them could sit down
in an air-conditioned smoke-free mineral
sipi mineral water sipping environment
and play poker and that's why the game
was so radically democratized during the
late 80s and the 90s and women streamed
into the game there are now seven
world series of poker tournaments have
been 17 times by women in in 2002 the
first million-dollar prize in a poker
tournament was won by kathy liebert and
it's it's the old Texas Cowboys the road
gamblers still are part of the game but
it's definitely a dying breed and
regular folks people who learn how to
play the game by reading books
practicing on computer programs have
increasingly dominated the winners the
final tables in the winter circles again
without giving too much away that's how
you practice to go out there right and
you didn't get together with mr. no last
name back there and practice with your
buddies it was computer I mean you just
churned and churn did you not I had
played poker for 40 years and i was
playing an irregular game at the time
but well most of those games are the
betting structure is limited the game as
it is played in the World Series of
Poker is no limit texas hold'em so that
union it's a very different sort of
rhythm usually in a friendly home game
the person who has been dealt the best
cards that evening will win the most
money and if you've been dealt terrible
hands all night you're going to lose the
most in in no-limit poker the experience
poker players have the leverage to bet
all of their chips at any one point so
that they're able to force you off a
hand even if you have a good hand they
can make you fold and have to leave the
pot it's called laying your hand down
and that is why No Limit Texas Hold'em
is preferred by professionals because it
gives them it gives the fact that they
have more experience gives them a huge
advantage over people there they terrify
people into giving up hands that would
win in most home games one of the other
things about poker that is interesting
to me a lot of people go to Vegas it
seems to me with the with the idea that
they're going to hit you know one of the
progressive slot machine
Thanks and I suppose that does something
to their neural circuitry but one of the
other things that distinguishes
positively fifth street is it Tim gets
to this he quotes a Harvard
neuroscientist how many books have you
read recently that border Harvard
neuroscientist that our good read orion
SAR harvard neuro scientists there one
guy back there the poker guy says the
same the same neural circuitry involved
in the highs and lows of abusing drugs
is activated by winning or losing money
anticipating a good meal or seeking
beautiful faces to look at when you
first sit down at the table and the arc
of you're playing in a very short time
how you become you're at first you're
kind of halting in your betting it's
sort of like working and you feel like
you're in slow motion because maybe
you've been playing the computer stuff
too much but you are second guessing
yourself the beginning of when he sits
down the first I play is just
fascinating because you are literally
and admit it most poker players don't
like to admit that they're scared of the
tables but you start second-guessing
yourself like crazy what happened during
the course of this thing that that
turned that around uh everyone in the
championship event at the World Series
of Poker cost ten thousand dollars to
enter I had when I went out there the
magazine had fronted me four thousand
and I used that to play a smaller
tournament in win a ten-thousand-dollar
seat starting on Monday morning we all
have the same number of chips and I was
I sank down to 2500 in about an hour and
45 minutes I went up to my room and
whimpered into the telephone to whining
whinging crying to my wife that I had
had this bad luck and I wasn't playing
well boo as sandy Murphy says throughout
the book boohoo
whoo-hoo and she came up with this
really terrible idea you know and I'm
playing against the best poker players
in the world and she says well you
should take the picture of the little
book that you carry with the family
pictures in it and put them on the table
next to your chips wow there's a
horrible idea but I didn't have any ID
isn't have any better ideas so I go back
down to the table and put this stupid
book next to my chips and the next thing
i knew i had 38,000 38,000 yep it's a
remarkable question that book that was
one that was one thing that helped me
poker is at forty fifty sixty seventy
percent luck depending on who you talk
to and my luck definitely changed when i
had talismans to inspire me the other
thing that that gives you a sense of
confidences even though you're playing
against famous players who are who make
whose job it is to intimidate other
people it's not as though you have to
beat Tiger Woods and around a golfer
play Kobe Bryant Michael Jordan
one-on-one you are if you get dealt the
better hand in that particular situation
you're gonna you're gonna you're going
to knock them out of the tournament you
get it the cards speak and once I had
won a few hands against the famous
players then I I understood
intellectually that that could happen
but you understand in a very visceral
emotional way I can win so was it was
the stupid pictures of my family and the
the fact that I caught a few hands in
key situations against famous players
and I quickly became known as the guy
with the the pictures it's very unmon
show you know you're supposed to have
maybe a six shooter in here and I had
these little pictures of my wife and
daughters yeah it's not the best
nickname I've heard in Vegas the guy Jim
the got out of the picture is McManus
yeah the family man's family man the
family man
and what a what a boring boring nickname
in plain gym one of the interesting
things is I know you may I may be wrong
but you're not we're not trained as a
reporter or a journalist but would you
come upstairs the amount of detail in
here is fastening even to the point and
this may seem minor to you that the
cards went down it whatever it is 136 is
when they hit the table in playing this
kind of intense poker and being a
reporter at the same time what did you
feel that balance going on were you
making notes instead of trying to tell
what this guy's tell was across the
table were you thinking oh my goodness
this man looks like looks like a you
know Richard M de leus all right well
there's there's two possible
explanations for how I pulled off
covering both stories at the same time
either I'm a towering literary genius or
the trial was being covered by 60 70 80
reporters the world series of poker is
being covered by 80 or 100 reporters and
I just stole their coverage and raided
it into my book I mean I knew what was
going on at the table as I was sitting
there but I certainly didn't know what
was going on two tables or ten tables
away yeah and I can't be Deb lock away
at the trial and in the tournament room
so every night and then in the in the
two years that I wrote the book I would
is that a sign that i am a towering
literary genius
the I borrowed heavily from the
outstanding work that the trial
journalists and the poker journalists
were producing every morning in the
newspapers TV and on the internet that's
that's how I did it then in trying to
take these various and I don't know if
there were piles of material but in
trying once you sat down and started to
write this book did you do it with an
outline nice i'm like Brian lamb how
many hours a day did you work did you do
it with an outline how did you structure
the thing going in well in moving from a
magazine article to a book what is
usually what usually happens is that you
have to write a proposal for a publisher
and then they give you a contract and a
little bit of money up front and they
want to have confidence that you have a
good plan so I was forced to write an
outline / proposal with many many pages
of written prose and then detailed notes
about how how I was going to proceed the
other thing that that factored into the
writing was that it was fun my hero a
Alvarez who chronicled the 1981 world
series of poker in the awesome book
called the biggest game in town which
everybody should read it's recently been
reassured in paperback he's written 17
or 18 books in his life he only had fun
writing one and that was his poker Las
Vegas book this book is about it's about
me and my family and poker and sacks and
Vegas is stuff that I won't I normally
don't stop thinking about anyway so it
was it was there was a lot of pleasure
involved in writing this book much more
so than in grinding out some other
writing projects that I've done
did you think at any point about the it
seems like you're saying that it was
kind of a liberating thing to write this
at any point did you did it feel too
risky for you did you feel that you were
sort of tackling more than you might be
able to weave because it is ah I can't
impress upon you enough how sort of
seamlessly these stories weave through
the book uh you know I'm sure some of
you and I've read it twice once I read
it to simply for the gamesman I had to
know how he did it what happened and
then went back and read it it's almost a
completely different book was it did you
feel you were the risk you were taking
in exposing yourself and your family and
and tying it together because you've
been awful lot here tying it together
braiding two or three or four plot lines
lines or themes was wasn't natural to me
because I had been a poet and a novelist
so that I that aspect of the writing was
something that I had 25 years of
experience in what was the risk taking
part that was not so easy was I had to I
had the book reveals a lot of intimate
details about my life growing up my
family life and
and so I needed permission from people
for example Jennifer to talk about
things that I had I was much more used
to writing about fictionally changing
names little details this was more or
less the straight truth I'm still in
trouble with my mom who was pretty
unhappy with the way that her father was
characterized in the book I thought that
I was lionizing him and showing what a
positive influence he was in my life but
since he was the I have two grandfathers
and one of them was the bad grandfather
and the other one was a good grandfather
thus leading to good and bad Jim and as
it turned out her dad was bad grandpa
tom and I'd meant that as a compliment
but my mom saw it differently I talked
to your mom absurd she seems really
proud of you now yeah maybe maybe
because I'm rich yeah there's nothing
like the New York Times bestseller list
what about what about the the shadow of
the of the biggest game in town which i
had read years ago Alvarez's book and
you quote him in the book here's a
here's a writer who would write in the
book that one of the players in the
World Series reminds him of a quote
fleshy west coast version of Saul Bellow
end quote did you feel the shadow with
that book at all I I welcome the shadow
i drape drape the shadow of Alvarez
around my shoulders I hope that I could
live up to his example he was a poet and
a nonfiction writer he was a basically a
literary generalist which is much more
in common much more common in Europe and
South America in other parts of the
world in America we tend to segregate
our writers into one camp poets
journalists fiction writers and so on
but Alvarez is a man of letters who was
obsessed with a number of things
including poker The New Yorker sent him
to cover the 1981 world series of poker
and he produced a masterpiece and I
wanted to do the same thing I was very
conscious that I was swimming in the
same
swimming pool every morning that was now
part of Binion's that Alvarez sometimes
pronounced see the pronounced Alvaro's
or Alvarez and he he had to sneak into
that pool because it was not part of
Binion's Horseshoe in 1981 and I was
very very aware and welcoming of the
fact that he had blazedd this trail for
me and I you know the book has a my book
as a substantial chapter about how
important his book is to my writing and
poker life you fin on something that
need be asked the joys and pains of
writing fiction as opposed to the joys
and pains of writing nonfiction now that
you have this majestic book under your
nonfiction belt and a number of books
under your fiction belt I'd love to know
what you feel are they the difference is
how you felt in the writing what that
creative process how it differs I I find
novel writing much much more difficult
than none non-fiction writing I'm
writing a currently I'm writing a book
about I got a check-up at the Mayo
Clinic and writing about middle-aged
guys faces mortality health care in this
country and around the world and I've
written four novels over the over the
course of 20 years and I novel writing
is hard one reason for at least for me
well and I one reason is that you have
to write every word every single word
you have to make it up you have to come
up with the words the sentences the
paragraphs and nonfiction writing at
least the way I do it you're you're you
do a lot of borrowing as i said earlier
i was using the trial journalist work
the poker journalist work and as I as I
recounted the history of poker I was
summarizing and
you know combining summaries and
quotations of what other people had I I
wasn't right it wasn't inventing the
history I was just reporting what other
people had written so that a good fourth
or third of the book consists of other
people's ideas which are of course cited
but I didn't have to create every single
notion and sentence in the book so to me
it was quite a bit easier you also
there's pictures in this book and that
and that takes up a lot of space and I
get paid for those pages but I didn't
have to do anything I want to ask Jim on
page 312 there's kind of a striking
picture of Jim wearing a Harper's hat
with an H on it when you see that
picture what do you think do you think I
would think to myself I would go man do
I look cool there or what can you buy
the book then you can take that you have
to buy the book to see the picture what
do you think when you look at that
picture I'm dead serious I be honest ah
it's a very weird pose that anyone
photograph of me sitting down at the
table so that's the one that they use it
it's not the best picture but it is in
fact me at the apex of my poker playing
journalistic life sitting down at the
big table I like the fact that I can
wear sunglasses indoors that's one of
the things that I talked about it pokers
a great excuse to wear sunglasses
indoors at night and I immediately went
on a diet after after i saw the tapes is
he the Discovery Channel people tape the
final table and i was told that cameras
put 10 pounds on you and my friends in
the poker game and some of my students
were asking me how many cameras were on
you the
and the other thing that the tape
reveals is that I i play too huge hands
in the tournament one probably the most
interesting hand in the book involves an
866 thousand-dollar pot that I played
against TJ cloutier many of you know is
the is the author of the best book about
how to play no limit hold'em and i had
more or less memorized his book in the
three months leading up to the
tournament long story short I ended up
playing four or five massive pots
against him and a late on the third
night of the four day event I was in
hooked up 866 thousand dollars between
us and the flop which are the common
cards between face up in the middle of
the table that everyone shares were
virtually identical to the cards that he
gives in a practice hand that I had
studied relentlessly he knew that I knew
about how he advised to play that hand
so I played it the opposite to the way
he advised and some I subsequently won
the pot I had no pair i just had a sking
he at ace nine and i took the lead in
the tournament so that was the high
point of my poker experience the other
big gum the other big hand that i played
was the next day and that was a 1.15
million million dollar pod against
hassan habib and i had a squeem he went
all-in I had a squeem I called him and
he turned out that he only a taste for
so I made a pretty good call because
there were only three cards and the deck
the other three fours that could beat me
all the other cars in the deck gives me
that huge pot and a real chance to win
the whole event however on Fifth Street
the final card dealt a four spiked and I
was out
and the cameras were rolling six or
seven of the mommy at one time and if
you if you're wondering what it feels
like to lose a 1.15 million dollars I
was when you're when you're way ahead
when you're the heavy favorite if you
look at the tape for on the Discovery
Channel looks like i have been shot in
the scrotum with a pellet gun so that's
that's how it feels it is her sins doing
so well and I'm still about trying to
give anything away here since doing so
well has there been a subsequent poker
tournament life for you I don't know
that yeah i have i've tried to i've
played in the world series of poker
every year since then i try to go to
four or five tournaments a year i teach
a course called the literature and
science of poker at these school of the
Art Institute and one of my students
asked me this year if you're such a good
poker player why are you teaching here
and I said one I love teaching and I
love writing and I never lose money when
I'm teaching or writing and poker
players you know poker players lose
money you know the best golfers and
baseball players and jazz musicians
never lose money when they're playing
but poker players even the best lose at
least forty percent of the time and
since the house is taking six percent in
dealers fees and hotels and and food you
really have to be good to beat a six
percent rate so that there's only two or
three hundred people in the world who
make their living exclusively from
playing poker and I ain't one of them
and I wouldn't want to try because it's
it's real nerve-racking you too
I know I've gotten to know many people
who do it and it their life is I I don't
envy them it's yeah it's fun it seems
fun to live for a month or two in Las
Vegas and play a lot i play a lot of
high-stakes poker but it when it becomes
year in and year out and you're just
getting killed by bad cards for long
stretches its it's not an appealing
option well because one of the one of
the hallmarks of hold'em is you you
occasionally in do a great job of
capturing this too and positively fifth
Street you have to sit there and just
kind of rain yourself in do you not as
the cards are coming you know something
you know in a friendly game at home you
might say oh sure I'll see the flop and
is that one part of it that it just can
get sort of stultifying Lee boring
sitting there and you you chomp at the
bit because you do need that kind of
action ah the world series of poker main
event has been characterized I think
fairly accurately as four days of
boredom it's now five days of boredom
interrupted by a few moments of sheer
terror that's the rhythm of it you're
sitting there waiting it's in a friendly
home games you're playing a lot of hands
you're drinking beer you're having pizza
with your friends and your conversating
as Michael Jordan used to say in in
serious high stakes poker just play a
much smaller number of hands but the
hands that you do play you play very
aggressively and there you can win a lot
there's a huge amount at stake when
you're in the pot otherwise you're just
sitting there observing how the other
people play so if you really understand
what your job which is to pick up tells
on people it's not boring but there's
not a lot of overt action going on it's
mostly observation I worry in that in
the two thousand tournament that you
were and I think there were 510 512 512
it's obviously grown each year since I
don't know if it's ESPN or discovered
you know but something now is I'm seeing
poker tournaments in London
clubs and all over the place is kind of
turning to me it seems like the
Professional Bowlers tour is that good
for poker I I think it's real good as
many and the people in the tent probably
realized the poker is now broadcast on
prime time on wednesday evenings on the
travel channel the World Poker Tour
final tables and the big sea change has
to do with the fact that the tournament
excuse me that the the players hole
cards are revealed they have little
cameras by the elbows so that you know
who's bluffing and who's holding an
unbeatable hand which makes watching
about a thousand times more exciting in
the old days watching poker on TV was
like watching bears hibernate and smoke
and yeah because the the object of the
game is not to give away any information
however in the new broadcast check it
out on Wednesday nights because my books
being advertised there I understand the
you know more than the players who are
playing in the pot know so it's pretty
exciting how did your uh man with the
beard and his other no last name crowd
treat you when you came back after
you're upset with total awe and respect
whenever I would whenever I would enter
a part of the Rays everyone never more
about or what hand they had it was
awesome actually was real and Jody will
coroner the New York Times did a little
profile she came to the game and wrote
about how I get absolutely zero respect
absolutely zero respect and that you
know that's one of the beautiful
terrifying aspects of poker is that the
best player in the game and I'm not even
saying that I am although I am and
it isn't going to win that often if
you're catching cards you're not
catching cards that's the most
determining factor in you know in a
limit game what about the success of
this book how has it changed the way
perhaps people in the book business
perhaps your students perhaps old
friends of yours in the literary
community looked at you well this is the
success of the book sales wise it's not
something that I pay attention pay
attention to I don't care about Commerce
I only care about art I teach at this
game yarder that 14 and 15 thing on the
New York Times bestseller list uh you
know the poker class gets it's a popular
class that it always has been for
obvious reasons the literary world it it
makes a big difference to publishers if
if the book I mean how selling also in a
practical term or respect now you know
our magazines beating down your door to
write pieces for them are you getting
pitches to write other non-fiction books
for instance like or you did such a
great job on this why don't you go play
you know Boris Spassky at chess why
don't you you know what I mean because
it's a their genres that one when you go
to follow up from harper's and in my
book publisher FSG has been and don't go
the World Series of Poker you go to the
Mayo Clinic and then my book publisher
has followed up with an equal amount of
interest I
in another non-fiction book they're less
dying to read my novel manuscript than
they are the nonfiction which I have
regrets about because I grew up my
heroes were Joyce and Beckett Irish
novelists and they would never stop and
pause and write nonfiction just so that
they could have more money to play poker
that because they're just too they're
too good to have done that so I do feel
a little bit guilty about doing it but
don't you think a success like this and
and perhaps even your next non-fiction
book will you know enable you to do what
what every fiction writer in the world
would love to be able to do to write
fiction unencumbered by worries about
bills unencumbered by worries about
bills that's a good one one of the
downside of a book like this is where
when you're saying a lot of edgy things
about people people in Las Vegas is that
they see that the books successful and
they suit you yeah so that we're at this
point in no sense are we uncovered by
worries about pills isn't your publisher
stepping up for you yeah they are it now
Walter Goodman the charming is at Walter
Walter give the charming mayor of Oscar
Oscar governor charming former
mob-connected lawyer sounds like you
know Chicago Chicago many years ago uh
he's mad at you isn't he my wife's got
her finger over her mouth and that means
good Jim should shut up so good gym is
going to shut up good we would be happy
and there's a microphone right over
there and this is being broadcast for
later presentation on c-span if any of
you would like to stand at that mic and
ask for instance what do you do in the
fifth spot holding a week we suited
queen Jack by all means there's a great
line the people asking Jim what he knows
he quotes David Mamet in this book from
American Buffalo Donnie asks and what
makes you such an authority on life all
of a sudden and teach replies my life
and the way I've lived it I think that's
what makes Jim I a an authority on and
he doesn't play it up he's an authority
on poker his authority on Vegas he's an
authority on his own life in the arc of
that mr. card players speak to me you're
the guy who has like a poker club aunt /
book club right that's that that's right
I just want to know if positively fifth
Street is assigned reading in your poker
class it is not I think it's a little
cheesy to to assign your own work
however if they do by the book there
there are bonus points they are
available and in the course in the
course the over the over this during the
semester the better they do on papers
and quizzes the more points they have
which translate into chips at we play a
tournament on the last day so that I
don't look askance on the people who
bought the book I looked with favor upon
them I'm not one of those teachers to
preach that pretends that he likes all
of their students equally some of the
students I like more and some of them I
don't like at all what do you like about
teaching uh well it's been especially
gratifying for the last seven years
because we have a graduate program in
writing at the at the Art Institute a
lot of people don't know about that a
lot of people don't even know that the
school the Art Institute exists is
actually older than the museum and
working with people who are dedicating
their entire lives to becoming writers
is it's real exciting I feel lucky to be
able to show them a few things that I've
learned myself sir you have a question
I'm interested in learning how do you
maintain your concentration levels
during the four-day event in terms of
sleep patterns and diet I talk look it's
a lot of those I talked extensively
about it I cut down I didn't drink at
all I tried not to eat any red meat I
swam in the pool every morning it's it's
not a physical confrontation but physics
aminah is certainly there's a physical
dimension to stamina so I and a lot of
other players try to take good care of
themselves for example there's a there's
an Irish name Irishman named per egg
Parkinson who's a fairly heavy drinker
but he doesn't drink at all between
january first and the end of May he
basically drinks for half the year and
the other half he spends preparing for
the bin sh if his game other people
don't follow those regimens and it is
certainly possible to play but the more
the more alert you can be over the
course of five days the better chance
you're going to have I think any other
questions I can't believe you haven't it
how many of you read the book how many
of you have loved the book mom
he's got a great family back there you
get two adorable little girls you just
got a dog right yeah his name is abuzz
and I've been hired to write this is
great I'm not the dog person in the
house and was sort of the anti dog
person but now Esquire has hired me to
write about my decision about whether or
not have a decision that I'm making with
Jennifer about whether or not I'm going
to get a vasectomy and whether or not
we're going to neuter buzz and they feel
sort of like this feels like the same
decision in a sense it's called Pearl
Jam Stan okay let's talk about vegas for
a second you either in an interview or
something said if you haven't been to
vegas vegas about if my memory serves
correctly about 10-15 years ago decided
because steve wynn decided that vegas
should become this family-friendly place
and they built an amusement park at the
MGM Grand and it was going to be the
great place for families it was for a
while just out of curiosity people came
that's been a bust it's now if you see
the Vegas commercials you have people
writing postcards and then erasing the
postcards and it's kind of a well if if
it happened to you here we'll keep it a
secret right what does that say about I
mean Vegas was being the the playground
it's a nice for bad Rick and bad Jim and
even maybe bad Jennifer Idol I thought
she could be bad no such thing but you
know what I mean it's a place where
people feel now certainly to be
unencumbered by a certain
the moral code that they might have in
Des Moines family Vegas is more or less
fading and it but it's not it's not
sleazy old school Rat Pack Vegas right
now it's I think of it as more of as
more euro Vegas the big new casinos are
themed on posh European resorts and
cities Paris the Bellagio Venetian the
Venetian and even Caesar's Palace is
based on a ancient Rome so it's much
more about decadent dining wine drinking
and so on fabulous pools and than it is
really about gambling but it's not the
most kid-friendly place in the world
it's not it's not hostile toward kids
but it's it's more of a place it's more
of an adult playground then then it was
ten years ago and it's not just gambling
him in the other day I hate to use this
phrase bethey light motif of Vegas's as
it always has been i guess is sex ah
they know no there's no sex in Vegas
that I'm aware of
when there's a wonderful all seriousness
but it doesn't you know some of the
hotels are two billion dollars marble
great chefs and so on but when I when
poker players go there it's a table
shape roughly like this a little bit
shorter a little bit wider and then
you're just sitting there like this and
you're concentrating here's your cards
and here's the flop and here's the board
and that's about it you know everything
else you play for 14 hours and you go to
sleep and you eat breakfast and you come
back you start playing again and you go
get on the plane and fly home that's
that's what Vegas is for me is your
family been there have you taken the
family there your wife and two beautiful
girls have they ever been there have
they ever expressed the end is a month
we're gonna go are you really yeah as
long as I don't get whacked in the
meantime we plan to to be there no more
questions it is a remarkable book it's
not just about poker it's not just about
Jim McManus it's not just about vegas
it's not just about a person of man of
Jim McManus's age of the way in which he
weaves all these things together is
really remarkable for not being a
journalist it's like that aspect of it
as we use in the business the best clip
job I've ever read we got the
information of a trial by just you know
watching CNN and taking this stuff it's
a remarkable thing I mean I can't do and
those of you who buy this if you're not
interested in nonfiction there are a lot
of booksellers here go buy the novels
and short stories because it's about
time with someone to watch one of the 86
to watch in 86 the Tribune is not right
all the time but 17 years later they
were right about you thank you thanks
Rick
James McManus is author of the novels
going to the Sun and out of the blue his
latest work positively fifth Street is
published by Ferrar Straus and Giroux on
the web at FSG books calm